I have faith in consumers but will never
depend upon them to solve all the
challenges that they that we face I mean
yes the marketplace is important and
there are more and more consumers every
year vying green and sustainable
products that's a good thing but
consumers face some fundamental
challenges when I talk to young people
they constantly ask me why are the good
things expensive and the bad things
cheap we have created an economic
construct through rules and regulations
and tax codes that allows businesses to
escape from most of their negative
impact so if you're an automobile
manufacturer and you sell a car that
gets poor gas mileage and that poor gas
mileage creates a lot of air pollution
that translates into increased asthma
allergies cancer you as a manufacturer
there are no responsibility for those
negative impacts those negative impacts
are dumped onto society and we pay those
negative impacts as a society now I
think that if you're going to do bad
stuff if you're going to be a farmer and
use pesticides that pollute the
groundwater you should have to pay for
all those negative impacts and if that
was the case if traditional growers of
food paid the full cost of soil erosion
water pollution adverse health effects
on their farm workers because of
exposure to pesticides something quite
amazing would happen organic food would
cost half the price of what traditional
food would cost and we wouldn't ask
consumers to make a very difficult
decision which is do the right thing
make the right choice by the sustainable
product but don't get any financial
benefit for making that choice so
ultimately we have to change the system
we have to change the economic lands
so that business and consumers are all
aligned and incentivized to make the
sustainable choice you shouldn't have to
pay extra to buy a hybrid car you
shouldn't pay extra to buy organic
clothing those products are better and
more sustainable and more responsible
for the planet and they should cost less